this is the world's first malaria
vaccine
and today it's baby teddy's turn
he's six months old and this is his
first dose to protect him against the
killer disease
she tells me the vaccine has greatly
reduced the number of very sick children
coming to her kasumu clinic
but not all are protected
we don't just test all the children for
malaria
like this one here has a fever the
mother says the child has got fever
vomiting and cough so these are suspects
for malaria because one of the critical
symptoms of malaria is fever
the vaccine will be rolled out across
sub-saharan africa to the communities
that need it most
we drove a few hours south of kisumu to
a town that is in desperate need of help
this
is homer bay
a small fishing town that lies on the
shores of lake victoria
vaccine isn't just going to save lives
it's going to save entire health systems
from collapse here in homer bay they're
dealing with not one but three health
emergencies all at the same time there's
hiv
malaria and we're still in a pandemic
this town has one of the highest rates
of hiv anywhere in kenya one in five
people here are infected
malaria is endemic and any outbreak here
will have devastating consequences
[Music]
bella came to hospital three days ago
her little body had swollen to twice its
normal size
she had a high fever
and is severely malnourished
blood tests confirmed
bella has both hiv
and malaria
her grandmother needed counseling but
the news was broken to her
it's a relief to know what's happening
to bella so i at least know how to
manage her illnesses
bella was born with hiv but after being
abandoned by her mother when she was
just two
she was never screened
homer based director for public health
dr gordon okomo told me cases like
fellas are sadly common i call this one
triple tragedy because they were
battling with the
communicable diseases at the same time
we're battling with the non-communicable
diseases and of course we're in the mix
of the pandemic
so this is taking toll on the health
systems
and of course if you look at this
in the mix
is crazy
bella's malaria and hiv treatment has
started it was lucky she was diagnosed
in time
doctors are confident she will survive
the malaria vaccine will mean
homer bay could in the future have one
less health crisis to worry about
joshi sky news houma bay
west in kenya